[inaudible]
do you want to be today is a comedian,
actor and podcasts there.
Nick Depalo,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Next.
Dave,
how are you?
I liked it.
The first thing you said to me was to have to worry about any language here.
Yeah.
Which you ought to drop it right now.
You want to drop all your,
all your passwords notified.
Like you said,
I've seen you on youtube and it looks like a TV.
So I felt like I was walking into meet the press and yeah,
this is very professional.
Yeah.
Well you got the,
you know,
I wore a jacket for you though.
How I was going to put a tie on for you.
That would have been a bit much.
Yeah,
that's what I thought he would have seen right through that.
Does anyone want to see a comedian in a tie?
Only if the hanging themselves say something wrong.
Well that's,
I think that's going to be the theme of everything we're doing here.
Uh,
so for the people that don't know you,
give me a little,
a little background on Nick Depalo pre stand up,
please stand up.
Did you have a life before if you call it a life.
All right.
I'm on my head a heartbeat now.
He's breathing.
Yeah.
I grew up about 22 miles north of Boston and the very middle class white suburb
pretty much.
And uh,
went to college at University of Maine and uh,
came out of college,
took a job selling frozen steak and seafood door to door out of the back of it.
And so it was a pickup truck that actually seems like a good credibility to
stand up.
It was a great prayer.
I'd walk into places,
I'd lay out all my stuff.
Like I'd go on and say any,
any,
any residents,
small businesses.
I'd go into a real estate plan.
I lay out all my stuff if they let me in.
And uh,
you know,
there would be 20 people firing questions.
How much is that per pound,
Buh,
Buh.
And it was great.
I'd make them laugh and,
and uh,
you know,
this stuff was really overpriced.
It was a boiler room operation and I'm sure there's people that have seen me on
TV since cause then I'm going to find that I bought Haddock for 85 bucks a pound
from that year.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I did that for a few years and then they took a job.
We haven't see those companies late at night.
That market inventions,
if you have an idea for it.
Oh yeah,
I did that and started where we're meeting.
You did one of those infomercials?
No,
I was,
I actually was a uh,
a salesman.
Like I have my own corner office,
another boiler room operation.
Wow.
Jeez.
Which I didn't know when you come out of college will take a legitimate threat,
a nice building.
I got a suit on and stuff you find out.
But,
but the,
the biggest one that I took a job with New England rare coin galleries in
Boston.
It was like working at Merrill Lynch.
It was on the 31st floor of a skyscraper.
I had to wear a suit.
It looked just like a,
you know,
Charlie Sheen of Wall Street when I went to work.
So I did that for,
that was brutal.
I'm trying to sell $50,000 coins over the phone to somebody you've never met
before.
This is after selling the steak and seafood on a tour.
Yeah,
there's [inaudible] ground that didn't last long.
Right.
So I quit that,
that,
that I quit that and about a month later I'm watching TV.
I see my boss being led out by the,
by the FBI knows ships.
It was like a boil,
another boiler operation.
Some of the coins were fake and,
but uh,
but I started doing stand up,
uh,
you know right at,
right after that,
probably a cup a couple of years out of college.
And this is in Boston,
in Boston,
a place called stitches.
There's a,
there's a document you've probably seen stand up,
stood out and that little club where they're interviewing people,
stitches.
That's the first place I did my first joke open.
Mike.
Yeah.
I was drunk at a cookout at my parent's house and like good parents that gave me
the keys and said,
I want to try.
So yeah,
I put my name and sure enough,
I get called a,
it was a Sunday night.
I pull up the stitches and Boston and on the Markia and never forget it says it
said comedy.
Hell,
that's what,
so that was my first,
George McDonald was the house this guy had and Boston,
my first line on stage was an ad Lib and that's when he said to me,
I knew you're going to be funny.
I followed some guy in a Tuxedo and a,
I have like a sweatshirt on and then,
and I'm like,
I didn't know what to how to dress.
And I said,
I didn't know how to be following him at fucking Mr. Sanders,
which is a local Tuxedo place.
And that got like a nice laugh and then I bombed it the next four minutes.
Yeah.
And uh,
I was stupid enough to go back.
Yeah.
So that's pretty,
that's pretty much the beginning of everybody.
Right.
You don't even know how to screw up at the beginning.
That's right.
So you're kind of good by accident or something like that.
That must've been a magical time in Boston.
I mean,
that's what the documentary is hip,
but they were major,
major comics.
They're all doing it seemingly for the right reason.
Yeah.
More before they even knew what,
what stand up could become the yeah.
Yeah.
And it still to this day,
you think about the people that have come out of Boston.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
Jay Leno,
Conan,
Joe Rogan,
Louie Belieber,
uh,
myself,
even Kevin,
meaning Jenny graphql and moved to Boston at the time.
Yeah.
And yeah,
it was a crazy Steven Wright.
He's a,
yeah,
he's a legend.
Yeah.
I mean,
so it's,
it's a crazy,
but that was,
it reminds me of good fellows that they're going to,
it was a glorious time.
I had a pot of,
had a plot of coke next to my bed.
How many condoms?
Uh,
it was,
it was unbelievable.
How can you get cut the garlic?
What's that?
How thin did you cut the gold?
Very thin with the,
that you could do that metaphor there.
You could do that mix.
Yeah,
exactly.
It Nixa that's how they get paid to comedy club.
You could get paid and coke or money.
And so there were a lot of drugs.
Yeah.
I wasn't a drunk guy.
I played,
I was a jock.
I played football in college and,
and,
and uh,
but they would kick me out of the green room.
Steve sweeting and Gavin and all of our veterans.
A rookie.
You going to do the Shit and get out?
Yeah,
I'm standing out.
One time I tried to John Pinette talk me into,
uh,
after about a year and a half,
he talked me to doing a line.
I go up on stage at mix,
I'll never forget it and I'm talking about,
I have cotton mouth from the Co.
My lip keeps getting stuck like this.
I have my hand in my pocket and I want to point,
it was quiet around this set of guy yells,
hey,
relax up there.
I was Jig jiggling my car keys.
Oh,
from comics in the back when Diane,
I kept it,
I kept tripping over my punchlines cause my mouth was,
my lip kept getting stuck in my teeth.
That was how he didn't die early.
I mean,
he's the only,
but I love them so much.
So I actually said I'll do it right at you.
I don't mean any disrespect to him,
but if he was doing a lot of cooks somehow the weight thing didn't make snow
snakes.
Yeah.
Was he was putting on cheeseburgers and you know,
I don't know,
but I'm,
so that was the beginning of that following guys like Lenny Clarke and Steve
Sweeney,
these guys are legends that your fans probably don't know who they are.
But to this day,
I mean Kenny Rogers and these guys were as good.
Now I'd been doing it 30 years later and I still haven't seen anybody,
you know,
Baraka Room like that with a material,
you know.
So what do you think happens to to that type of guy?
Because I don't even know those guys really like that.
The guys that don't make it,
cause I know,
I mean this is the same old story that we all have,
but like some of the worst comics that I started with have become successful and
some of the best and most actually of the guys that I thought were really great.
All right.
Completely disappeared.
And we all have that story.
Well,
the guys in Boston,
there was a a couple of reasons and it was so big.
Comedy standup was booming in the mid eighties,
late eighties.
And that was the Mecca like you said.
But these guys,
like Nick's comedy club held like 350 people and it was just a moneymaking
machine and it was run by the boys.
And they had like some of the guys sign agreement saying they couldn't perform
anywhere else,
but they will making,
this is back in the 80s.
I remember one of the guys tell me they were making three grand and 3,500 a
weekend.
Jeez.
So why would you late right in the cities,
it's not like you even had to go.
Yeah.
You didn't have to go on the road in their homes.
And they,
you know,
and like I said,
they party their ass off and,
and they signed some of them signed agreements and that they couldn't perform
elsewhere.
So that's what,
but I mean it will make killer money.
Didn't have to get on a plane and,
and um,
but by the,
in the,
in the long run was saying,
you know,
who are they?
But Steve Sweeney has been in a few fairly brother movies and,
and,
and learning clock was brilliant.
I saw these guys at their,
uh,
Kevin Meeney.
Yeah,
they had a,
I always love Kevin Meeting.
Unbelievably Sweeney meeting night.
They call,
I was a bar back at stitches comedy club before I come.
That was the other job.
I for about six months.
I just want her to be near it,
you know,
and it was sweetening meaty night.
It was Kevin,
Kevin Maney in Steve Sweeney,
who is the godfather of comedy.
Uh,
and they would,
they would,
uh,
yeah,
they had a show on Wednesday nights.
Kevin meeting would go out on the street with a camera alive and the a scream
and come down in the club so the audience could watch and he would pull over
buses,
get on buses and stop making fun of people on the boat.
Uh,
him and Sweeney went into,
uh,
the Chinese restaurant next door swing.
He's got like a cutout of a cop with his face,
throat.
He's pretending he's like a food,
uh,
yelling at the Chinese people to clean up the kitchen.
Then they go into a lady's room and there's a woman in the stove.
It kick open the door with a camera
picture crowd in a glove would not fly these.
No,
of course not.
There'll be too much fun.
And uh,
but picture that people inside.
Well I've never heard laughter like that.
And I like Kevin,
Kevin,
me,
he waved down a cop and started giving the cop shit and a cop got mad.
You are watching this on a screen inside.
I mean brilliant,
brainy and you know,
it was,
uh,
unbelievable time.
There was more states,
more stages available than Comedians at there.
I've worked 300 nights my first year.
And because this is what,
you're around 88,
so this is like sort of sort of at the end of the boom,
boom boom,
right?
Yeah.
Cause,
what do they say that when dice sold out Madison Square Garden,
like three nights in a row,
that was when the whole thing shattered basically,
which I think was around 90 or 91.
Yeah,
that sounds about right.
Yeah.
But every I worked,
it's tough for these guys to,
the game has changed so much,
but me and Louis C K came up together.
He was already doing in a year or two before me.
I met him.
He was 18 and I was like 25.
And uh,
but every restaurant in pub in New England,
not just Boston,
I could show you my book for my first year.
Monday night I'd be a Chinese restaurant,
Rhode Island.
Tuesday night I'd be at some Mexican restaurant in Franklin,
mass.
Wednesday night I might do a college.
Thursday night I'd be a National Hampshire at a Holiday Inn,
uh,
you know,
and audit and seven nights a week there was so much stage time as you know,
as a stand up,
there's nothing more important.
And we thought that's how it was.
We didn't realize it was a boom going on.
Yeah.
We thought this is how it is.
So I quit my day job.
I was making more money.
After about 10 months,
I could handle a rough Rome.
I mean,
that's pretty crazy.
After 10 months I oil,
I could handle,
I could handle a rough Rome and some of the rooms are rough,
the one nighters.
And I've got the reputation that I could close these.
There was one Kingston and Kingston mass down in the Cape and it was a pool hall
and hey,
let's go to have a bucket of blood room.
And um,
I went down and,
uh,
these people literally playing pool in the back while they're doing mice,
but by the end of it,
they had put their pool sticks down and the guy that ran the place said this.
He's the first guy that ever had those guys come in.
And I got,
so I started to close rooms after Buddy Barry Katz was by management.
Yeah.
He,
he,
he booked every Roman New England.
So I had worked every night and uh,
you could make,
you know,
I was making on the weekends I'd make six,
700 $800 in cash and I was,
you know,
making about as much as I was during the day.
So I quit my day job.
That's crazy.
Cause you for your time,
right?
No,
no.
10 month comedian in New York City.
If you make 600 bucks in a year,
even now I think you're,
you're running thrilled.
Right.
I feel I would feel bad for these younger.
Yeah,
it's a whole different game.
What do you make of just sort of,
you know,
when people say,
well,
comics are all just messed up and the whole thing,
what do you make about the pain to comedy that drags all of us in there?
I think some of it's overblown.
I didn't,
you know,
I mean we're all,
we all have a screw loose somewhere,
but this whole stuff that,
you know,
it,
it has to be the kids who were bullied and I don't buy that.
Even Bill Hicks had a bit about that,
that he didn't buy into that either.
Supporting his parents,
supported him,
whatever he did,
blah,
blah.
Which is sort of the way I was very quiet and serious as a kid.
Yeah,
me too.
You and I bullied as much as I was blamed.
Nobody likes to say that,
but it's the truth.
That's the point we bullied.
I've been bullied and I bullied mic.
We're losing a lot of social justice warrior credit right now.
We're supposed to be victimized.
That's not what I'm here for,
man.
Bill Hicks,
I,
I Miss Bill Hicks.
I mean he was a little before my time,
but like,
but like that,
that relentless pursuit of truth and stand up.
Yeah.
And,
and he was politically to the left,
but he was really funny and hateful about,
yeah.
I mean that was his conviction.
That's what I learned from watching him.
Even to this day when I have a joke in my head and I'm like,
I don't if I should say this or not.
I use sort of him as a barometer.
Yeah.
But you know,
he was on the left.
He wasn't getting too much trouble showbiz wise,
but he said some,
you know stuff.
Yeah.
The way he used to talk about rush Limbaugh and stuff.
I do the same thing to Nancy Pelosi.
Yeah.
Well his little bit about Leno,
regardless of what you think about little,
I mean it's one of the,
it's one of the,
it's so absolutely pro.
It's just perfection is head blows.
Shelly Peacock,
I mean,
come on doc.
Is that a red jacket or is that done?
Is brains.
Yeah,
it's,
it's pretty perfect.
He Yanks and the,
I have a lot of that in me.
I have that chip that he had for,
I don't know,
for whatever reason I was born like that,
you know?
And that's what I loved about them politically.
You know,
he used to always say there's nobody out there that could hurt us when,
you know,
talking about Ay ay rack or whatever.
Right.
You know how we have the biggest military,
they have the third bay,
whatever.
This is nobody outdated.
It's a fucking threat to us.
I'd like to have bring them back to life and go,
you know,
tell them about nine 11 you know,
so,
but,
but he was so he was what a writer and you know,
I don't have to be on the same side of you.
Politically defined.
You're funny.
Yeah.
But I find that,
do you find the left doesn't do that?
Yeah.
All right.
So let's,
let's shift.
They're a little bit,
so what do you think has happened to stand up in the last say?
Well now it seems like 20 years,
but in the last couple of years especially,
it's gone from where it was seriously edgy,
where every,
every morning I wake up now and I'm like,
man,
I wish George Carlin was still alive.
Not only cause I think it was the greatest stand ever,
but we need still some of that,
although he be getting booed off college campuses because he's an old white guy.
Yeah.
But he was,
he,
I,
you know,
I love Carlin.
He got my idols too,
but he was a lefty and he won.
He created this environment and,
but he was more,
I mean he was most,
I guess he was a lefty,
but he was relentlessly against political.
Correct.
So that shows you how some of that stuff has changed.
But what do you make of sort of what's happened?
I was telling you right before we started,
and the only reason I'm doing stand up now again,
is because so many of these comics now,
uh,
have become the politically correct children that they're supposed to be making
fun of.
And I was like,
I guess I gotta go do it again.
And now I'm doing it again.
It's a bit bizarre.
I blame,
and I'm not kidding,
the feminist movement there at the core,
they are at the core of all this politically correct or shit that drives us
nuts.
They,
they are at the core of it,
the whole,
I think society has been feminized.
Yeah.
Uh,
we,
you know,
guys,
and again,
I'm generalizing here,
but for the most part,
even the loosest generalization,
we'll just,
cause I know
that's what they want though.
They want us to be walking around qualifying every statement.
I don't mean everybody,
you know,
example,
which I use it down.
Yeah.
That's one thing I do in my act.
I don't try to balance it out.
Yeah.
Pylon and um,
but,
but sensitivity,
pcs Bence is based in sensitivity.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and that's not an Idna lead.
And most guys,
you know,
I,
and they have a never,
they're never ending list of grievances.
They just,
they can't leave it alone.
I don't watch movies anymore.
I stopped about 20 years ago because I was aware of,
it's something made me aware of it.
I,
I can't suspend my disbelief and watch Angelina Jolie beat up 10 marines.
I just can't fucking do it,
you know?
I really can't.
Yeah.
And a,
I just,
it's been feminized and,
and this business draws a lot of people who were bullied and shit.
Even back in the,
in the 80s when I would watch films,
I go,
why is,
and I would say this,
this was way before I was in comedy.
I go,
why is the bad kid at the high school?
Always the white kid with a leather jacket,
the jock and every,
and it's still going to stay.
This is 30 years later,
back to the future.
Everything is this.
I mean,
I know it's just,
um,
you know,
there's a lot more women comics and,
and,
and whatever.
But th that's what the PC comes from.
It comes from the left.
Nobody ever says that the census shit,
I know people are bought into it.
Politicians on both sides in guys of Acquia.
I guess this guy's fault that we let it get this far.
Is it weird how it flip though?
Like,
cause you could look at say the 90s when the right was screaming about video
game violence and all this stuff and it's like,
no,
it doesn't cause real violence.
If anything,
it actually confuses.
So this is where it's like,
to me,
the right doesn't get a pass.
They have the right is way better now in terms of political correctness and free
speech.
Um,
but,
but yeah,
the left has become,
well yeah.
[inaudible] it's one thing to yell above video game violence.
Why,
which may or may not be true.
Whatever.
I never bought into that.
I watch the three stooges from age 60,
40.
I never fucking,
I never hit my mother would have with a crowbar.
Oh my mother in the eyes.
But uh,
um,
yeah,
they were wrong in some stuff,
but,
but not to the degree that the left gone with changing the political correct is,
you know,
the definition is,
changing people's behavior through language and you know,
with the today it's going the he and the,
she I want to be called gay.
And I'm sorry that I didn't ask about your pronouns before we started.
I'd like to be,
I don't even know what they call me,
them it yet,
but most people call me.
So that was kind of funny.
Do you remember,
uh,
do you remember when it started seeping into the clubs?
Um,
not,
I don't,
there's no one specific moment.
You know,
I've been doing this 31 years or whatever.
So I finally,
after all this time,
people come out to see me.
They know what's coming.
You know,
but I do remember early in my career,
I was at Clark University.
I was doing a college and Clark Universe,
I think it's Clark and Massachusetts,
even liberal for Massachusetts school.
That's liberal.
Yeah.
And I did some joke,
uh,
about the Middle East and got a gas station.
He couldn't find my oil.
He was trying to chat.
I said I had the one Middle Eastern guy who came couldn't find or whatever,
and some kid in the front row college,
you've got sure.
He goes,
Jesus,
that was a fun,
what are you going to do?
A Bush and jokes and acts.
So I just rattled off like eight abortion jumps off the top of my head and the
whole place was,
yeah.
And it's the only time I got off stage.
A couple of minutes early.
Really?
Yeah.
So that,
that was a long time ago.
But um,
I don't know if you say it with enough conviction.
Um,
I,
I don't know.
I get,
I get a thrill out of it.
These are good and bad times,
but I've always,
even after my first open mic,
about six months in my open mic experiencing a comic said to me,
you are politically incorrect.
That's,
that's where it's headed.
And even I said to him,
I go,
it's going to get a lot worse.
That this was like an 88 or 89 yeah.
And it did get a lot worse.
Do you think it can get much worse than no.
And I mean now you see articles in buzzfeed every day about stand up either
needs to be not funny now we should enter it,
you know?
Did you see that article did see we should enter a phase where stand up
shouldn't be funny so that we could address compensation.
We're even having that compensate stand up.
That's the antithesis of you stand as close to be.
You're supposed to say what people won't say.
And,
and that's in the DNA of a comic.
I mean in high school,
if I saw an opening in class for a joke that,
you know,
let it fly and the,
I can't believe it's to this point,
but I don't know where else it can go.
Well,
I can go in the direction that,
you know,
they'll force clubs to stop booking people and they'll kick the rest of us off.
[inaudible] a black market will pop up like anything else when you prohibit
something,
right?
Yeah.
And then I'd get really good fun.
Then we have a civil war,
then we,
then we go,
right.
Yeah.
Can we have the Goddamn war?
I'm on the side with all the guns.
You can go right there.
I'm on the side.
I pulled a gun.
Okay,
let's get it on.
I'm tired of it,
man.
I,
but,
uh,
at least I can set by now at least I market myself and people know at thanks to
my podcast and,
and uh,
after 30 is a standard,
but I was never,
I always,
I said stuff on tough crowd.
I called A,
we showed a commercial and I said,
that's cultural.
The Cultural Marxists that people are right.
They shit.
And everyone's like,
what's he talking to me?
And I got like pigeon hole that day.
Right.
You know,
that's gotta be at least 10 years ago.
So that's before these 10 years ago,
I was reading a lot of,
uh,
Pat Buchanan who I still up.
Okay.
What do you,
uh,
so you were in a tough crowd crew.
Colin Quinn obviously,
and that whole crew,
that show,
it was only on for a couple of years actually,
but it probably would never,
well not probably,
you would never make it on comedy central now.
Oh God,
no.
You know,
they actually said to Collin,
who's a genius,
Collin girl grew up in,
if you,
you know,
yeah.
I mean,
he's the sweetest guy.
As bright a guy as you'll ever meet.
He grew up in Brooklyn and I went to high school,
black kids,
Puerto Rican,
Dominican.
He knows that world.
Yeah.
And they actually said them after a few episodes,
a tough crowd after or a couple of seasons.
They said,
why don't you let leave the race stuff to Chapelle.
Can you imagine him saying that?
The colon that's actually racist.
I mean that of course it is.
Yeah,
of course it is.
People love that chokes me and Patrice.
Me and Patrice would unload on each other and people love me for,
I was on a plane in Atlanta right up to me and Beatrice had a good,
uh,
toe-to-toe,
on the show and I was a plant in Atlanta and I see this black guy look at him
with his son and I'm getting a little nervous and they come up to me and they
go,
we love you man on tough crowd.
Yeah.
And it's like,
you know,
people,
why don't you meet people face to face?
That's what sort of,
cause you clearly have a good disposition,
especially for a comic.
Is that partly what it is?
Like I see this now after being on tour for the last year.
If I go online,
it's just like an endless hate festival.
Lunacy.
Everyone's trying to destroy each other.
Yeah.
And then every night when I'm touring and I do meet and greets after the show
and all of these people and nobody cares what sex they are,
sexuality or bipolar and everyone's great.
So I feel like I live in these alternate worlds where the real world happens to
be pretty damn good.
It is.
And it's not just social media,
just the,
just the mainstream media.
I'll be laying there watching TV and all of a sudden a PSA.
Oh come on for the bullying.
Jesus Christ's.
Leave it alone for five.
I can't watch a red sox game.
I'm from Boston.
New England sports network is the most PC.
I love my red sox.
I,
I had trouble.
There's always a,
Oh you've got 12 women from the main woman shelter here is kids with cancer.
It's like Jesus,
I go to,
I'm watching this to get away from that.
Yeah.
Well that,
look what,
look what happened to ESPN.
I mean they've destroyed themselves in the name of being woke and they didn't
give a shit that day.
They did.
They have that much money or that's Disney.
Nothing is more PC than Disney.
Yeah,
they're at the core of it toe.
So wait,
you mentioned we'll get,
we'll get there,
but I don't want to jump over Patrice cause you've watched a couple of your core
guys
died and then it's to this,
which is,
uh,
so Greg Giraldo was like on his way to becoming starved stars.
I used to live like two or three blocks away from him on the upper west.
And I remember seeing him,
I would see him all the time.
You'd have his two kids and you'd be walking them to school or whatever.
And I used to see him at Equinox at the gym and he,
he was fit and he seemed like he was like,
I used to look at them and be like,
we didn't really,
you know,
he kind of knew I was a comic,
but we didn't know each other.
But I would look at him and I'd be like,
Oh,
you're a comic who like became a human.
You actually became like a real person too.
And I thought of,
I sort of wanted to emulate that in a way.
And I remember I saw him at the gym one day and he's pumping and blah,
blah,
blah.
He was dead two days later and you're like,
it really threw me for a loop even though I didn't know the guy that well.
Yeah,
you've had a couple of guys in your crew that just,
yeah.
Portrays and,
and,
and Greg,
uh,
even now when I hear him on the radio,
you know,
if you listen to satellite and,
and I'm like,
ah,
I got a good line from a tree,
a Gra.
And it just,
it never really got over.
The Geraldo just shocked me when,
when,
when that happened,
he seemed too smart.
I mean he's a Harvard Guy,
law guy,
but that's what I loved about him.
He gave the lend some credibility to stand up,
uh,
and,
very bright kid and always.
Yeah,
he was always jovial and,
and you know,
and he would pick my brain,
he would watch me,
I was a little ahead of him and he would be all asking all the right questions,
you know,
about,
stand up and,
and uh,
and he was on his way.
You know,
like you said a and Patrice.
I just loved Patrice cause he's a Boston guy.
He's a curmudgeon and didn't have,
didn't hide his dislike for Whitey.
I hide my dislike for him or his friends in which that's why we liked each
other.
You know what I mean?
And,
and uh,
what a blow to lose those.
It's always the good ones,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Well only the good die young,
you know,
Sarah yourself middle lived til she's a hundred as well.
Patton Oswald and Kathy Griffin.
Oh,
well now you're talking about the people that drag me back in.
I mean,
those three particularly actually,
but there's a couple of others that,
these are the ones that are talking about,
we can't let Milo's book be published.
Doesn't matter what you think about Milo comedians talking about banning books.
I mean,
can you imagine if you said that
about whoever,
you know,
Belmarsh should not be able to write a book.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah.
I mean they are artists and they have four group thing.
Yeah.
Which is the quickest way to stifle any creative.
The little fascist Fox.
I hate them.
I try to be nice.
I actually texted pat nozzle.
I don't know him that well.
When his wife died,
I felt so horrible.
I texted him a couple times and then I read this stuff,
know that he says tonight,
I'm like,
I don't like this guy.
We should was him.
There's the line that up just busting balls.
Right?
Yeah.
Um,
but you know what I mean?
Ray and Sarah Silverman.
Who is she?
Yeah.
Well,
couldn't follow me on my worst night.
There it is.
So,
so what do we do to break that thing?
Because it does still seem to be spreading.
Like I get that there's,
there,
there's some
pushback now and they're,
well,
first off,
do you,
what do you consider your conservative?
I mean,
if somebody says,
I know,
I know it doesn't really matter.
[inaudible] I know,
but I,
I,
I'm like,
and Quince,
Colin Quinn's others too.
I don't know.
I got labeled that after a tough crowd.
Yeah.
But what were in show business,
right.
I guess,
I guess something,
this is show business,
uh,
and,
and Hollywood or wherever and show up is if you,
if you're out of out of 20 issues,
if you lean right on two of them,
you're not,
you're gonna have to.
Yeah.
So I kept getting pegged with that conservative,
conservative,
but I'm really not.
I,
I'm for the truth.
I call them as I see them and I'm sure,
you know,
uh,
conservatives back in the civil rights,
we're on the wrong side of that and that now these guys have them,
they're there.
They're on the wrong side to me.
Uh,
anytime you want to sensor.
but,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
uh,
I,
I'm pro gay marriage.
I don't really care about guns.
Um,
I can't say I'm prolife only because like I have a dead dying of Alzheimer's
right now.
And if I could put them out of his misery tomorrow,
I would.
And when I was young,
I was glad there was planned parenthood drown when I got in trouble with a few
girls or whatever.
So I'd be a hypocrite to say,
yeah,
but this way to me,
your bushings,
I'll go with that.
I mean,
this is ridiculous what's going on.
Yeah.
It's strangely that those positions,
which I'm with you,
I described myself,
I'm begrudgingly pro choice,
I think.
I wish I didn't have to be yet,
but I grudgingly I'd worried,
you know,
but I know,
I know several women that have had abortions in the last year.
I just,
I don't think I could take that away from them,
but I completely get the prolife side.
Right.
But even to take those positions,
you just said,
if you're going to take anything that's not on the progressive side,
you're,
you're one of the bad guy.
Yes.
Well that's what it is.
You have to check off all the boxes.
Yeah.
Well your ear at Nazi,
whatever,
which is this whole,
you're a big and who do you,
who do you think you learn?
You can label somebody that,
that that is to me,
you've never had a racist thought or a muttered,
a racist.
Then those are the only people who have the right to call me a bigger and then
that person doesn't exist.
I mean the sanctimony on it is fun.
I can't believe it.
Yeah.
My and my buddy Pete goes in and who's been on the show many times calls this
thing a secular religion and that's what it is.
Become a really jets what it is.
And these people,
yeah,
they put up before anything got,
you know,
we've got our work cut out for us.
Huh.
Uh,
I was say the solution is a war folks.
I don't know.
I mean we're all going to balkanize and break apart or whatever and whatever.
Well,
you know,
it's funny you say that,
but I do see this undercurrent of people talking about that now.
Do you actually think,
yeah,
that that's where we ended up eventually over years,
these ideas just keep percolating.
Everyone realizes how much they have in disagreement with their neighbor and
then we ended up in some horrible base.
I mean,
it's pretty much everything I've been fighting against.
I've been trying to get these sides to be a little more decent.
But,
but I get the impulse on that actually too big.
No,
there is no middle ground.
There is no the Senate.
I,
I use that analogy a,
it's like a athlete's knee and think of Bobby,
you,
ours,
my,
it's like a,
you know,
the cartilage is gone and now it's,
now it's bone on bone.
You know what I mean?
There's a,
yeah,
I mean witness such a gap.
We're seeing the world through two different lenses.
Yeah.
I don't see that closing.
I only seen him,
you know,
and social media is sort of through the gas on it and expedited.
Well,
what do you make about what's going on with the,
with the tech companies and censorship and all that,
because that also is another thing that should be right in a comedian's wheel
house.
And I don't see these guys doing it.
I see Seth Macfarlane telling,
uh,
you know,
saying the family guys not going to do a gay jokes anymore.
The Simpsons isn't going to put our pool in episodes.
The hardest working guy on the show who was completely welcomed,
who is an immigrant that changed homer stance on illegal immigration.
And again,
you'll get other things in this country talking about Indian weddings and
Hinduism and Vegan isn't a horrible,
horrible [inaudible] I'm off the TVS,
just disgusting.
Yeah.
But all of this,
it's all related to social media,
the way everyone just,
we can look at the past and immediately erase it and we were automatically going
to be better.
And all of this endless bullshit.
What do you make of all of that?
Well,
the tech companies have it out for us.
Are you starting that thing with Jordan?
We're working on it and I'll count you in.
I'll start patrion all right.
Yeah.
And you know,
and they looked at,
they've been fair to me,
but I,
you know,
I don't want to contribute to a,
yeah.
I don't know where their money's going.
Right.
You're in.
We'll have to discuss the rest of it.
Not when the cameras of course.
Yeah.
Leave it to me to bring them.
Um,
so I do,
um,
well even just related to that,
you know,
I saw one guy,
it's like a fairly well known,
you know,
verified blue check,
lefty attacking me and Jordan over leaving because you know,
Carl Benjamin and sorry I got to,
Rick had said the n word and he said it,
and the guy kept saying,
if he had said it with an a at the end instead of an r at the end,
it would have been okay.
And I thought,
you guys density,
you've will get completely,
really serious because then it would have been sort of an endearing,
or at least a colloquial way of saying it,
but he said it with a hard r,
even though the way he said it was against the outright anyway,
but putting aside reality for a second,
but I thought the way you people whittle down everything,
it tells you it's not even about a word.
It's about the intonation that you say the word.
It's like,
think about that.
Yeah.
Just that alone.
If you've never said anything right,
you've never said it one way or the other.
Exactly.
I corrected myself.
Uh,
yeah,
I mean proofs out silly.
Their arguments are.
Yeah,
but,
uh,
I love that clip that Louie that at governors said that clip that surfaced a
couple of weeks ago.
Yeah.
So what do you make of that?
So you and Louis go way back.
Yeah.
Obviously everyone knows what happened with him.
Give me the sort of,
look,
I,
I've said it a million times.
if he did that to my sister,
I would have punched him in the face or a front,
you know,
a girlfriend or whatever.
Obviously that was horrible behavior on his.
Yeah.
But
I mean,
capital offense,
right.
Rolling his life and career.
Get over yourselves,
ladies.
You know,
I lived with them,
I do a job on stage about it and I like,
let's say you have to,
let's differentiate between him and Harvey Weinstein.
I mean,
everybody's being lumped in now and a,
yeah,
what Louie did was horrible and stuff,
but I,
you know,
and then I do a bit of buddies.
I had lived with them for a year and a half.
I started his Dick maybe 10 times,
four times in essential.
So I love him.
He's,
he's a great father.
he's as smart a guy as I ever met and,
and he was all,
I loved him.
He was always a little reckless.
And,
and what do you make of that thing?
I mean,
it gets to where I talked about earlier or what we talked about earlier about
just comedians and sort of being messed up or whatever.
Like that thing about like he's got everything right.
I mean that paypal shot when he had that million bucks just sitting in there
cause he sold his special just like that.
Like everything.
He was respected by everybody.
Like and yet some other shit's still going down.
He,
and I think we're,
we all suffer from that at some level.
Like it's just,
it's part of the human condition.
Yes.
Yeah.
We're humans.
We have flawed,
he never,
Louis never cared about money even when he started to make it at the beginning.
And,
uh,
I was like his big brother,
he didn't even know how to handle money when,
when we were,
you know,
when we first met,
when we went to San Francisco,
we're doing the punch line.
Me and him are like co headlining something.
He goes,
I'm going out to rent the VCR.
This is back in the early nineties.
So we can watch movies at the hotel,
whatever.
And we both had literally,
I'd probably,
uh,
probably $900 net worth between,
he comes back with a $600 trumpet that he bought.
This is how he,
he,
I had to explain to them the,
you know,
the value of money and I still don't think,
um,
that's not what drives him.
I know you've got all that success commercially and all the money and stuff,
but he said he's the most interesting person I've ever met.
So what do you think you think he's doing the forgiveness machine,
right.
Basically,
I love what he did.
He waited,
he waited around and he saw the bitching and we'd be stuck his face out of two
minutes and people go and wild.
You've got to let me know when he's at the club.
When you kill babies,
you know what do you,
what the fuck is going on here?
So he stuck his face out.
We took the temperature of,
and it was a bunch of whining and stuff and he probably thought about mild,
but over a few months that,
fuck this,
I'm coming back and I'm throwing haymakers I love the way and all this stuff.
All the people know that you know,
before this that loved him now and now he's going to get,
and the comics too.
It's the comment.
Yeah,
but it goes back to that feminist stuff.
It always goes back to that,
you know?
So he gets,
he gets back in and then of course all the articles where now he's all right,
you saw all that,
you know,
there's going to be the king of the red states.
That's my,
I've been working at a 30 years.
I'll say I do is whip my dick out and I could,
um,
yeah.
And he won't be,
he know his comedy will be like,
it's always been,
I don't think he will be the,
you know,
but,
but I do have a problem with a few comics out there who are kind of famous who
are now getting the label as a,
you know,
a edgy and anti PC
who's edgy that you think is actually edgy these days.
May My whole
career.
We should do a show together.
We should do it.
Yeah,
we should.
Yeah.
All right.
We'll do something.
Uh,
edgy is edgy,
is doing jokes,
pushing Rachel,
what were the table of black people right there where you could get punched in
the fit that's edgy.
Not going and finding a Patton Oswald gone in front of the thousands of nerds.
And that's not edgy.
It never was,
you know,
uh,
made telling my how I feel about women,
certain ones,
you know,
the,
the feminist movement.
Yeah.
And doing stuff that could hurt you.
I've been doing my whole,
but you gotta be funny about it first,
right.
First take,
you have to be offering,
otherwise you end up preaching and,
and uh,
um,
like Billy burger is now,
he's getting labeled as kind of edge but Belize a very liberal guy and to me his
politics of the past help create this environment.
I love when they call them racist.
I was just at a wedding with him a couple of weeks ago.
He's white,
this black you eating,
you know,
I love his wife and he,
Billy is the least racist person or no,
can you imagine?
But,
but those guys,
you know,
I was pushing that along time ago and now I'll be like,
he's,
you know,
real.
And that's Billy saw burger right now to me is the funniest.
He's like every guy I grew up with a Boston just,
he sounds like every kid I grew up with and,
and brutally funny.
But my point being those,
I have bell Myra was getting all,
remember Belmont when after his own audience because of the Muslim thing and
stuff.
But,
but I said,
good for bill,
but bill,
you help create this environment.
You know,
I,
I'm,
so we caught with him because I loved him for so many years.
He was like my guy,
he was the right kind of liberal free speech,
liberal.
I loved him and I've always wanted it to be on the show and I want to do this
with him.
I really do.
But these last couple of years,
even though I think he's still on the right side on the free speech stuff,
but when he apologized cause of the n word Thai iced tea or whoever it was,
it was like,
she says,
this is bad,
this is bad.
And now his Trump stuff has gotten,
so he's like,
he's become like a character of a caricature of himself.
And I,
and I say that with like the most respect.
Like I want him to be better again or something,
you know?
Yeah.
But what does that tell you about just sort of the way television also has
changed because you've been on the tonight show,
you've been on Letterman,
you've been on all the late nights.
They seem completely irrelevant to me now.
I mean that,
oh,
I have,
I'm not putting you down.
You know what I mean?
No,
no.
Just like the machine has now changed leash.
I did it on Jay was there and I love Jimmy to,
well I love [inaudible] too,
but it's
a whole different and,
and my stuff,
I mean,
I wasn't,
you know,
when we start comedy at the beginning,
you create,
try to have a lot of kind of TV clean because you want to get some exposure.
Yeah.
So I wasn't super edgy,
but my first let him,
and I did mention like a gay woman,
I agree with me about her dog or whatever,
whatever,
you know,
I guess compared to what other people,
and I made fun of homeless,
my opening line or whatever.
So I guess that was kind of edgy.
I could at least work.
Then.
Now you're knocking on the tonight show with that.
Well,
it's funny.
At night I went to see my buddy,
Joe Lewis when he did his first Letterman and the girls said that they wanted me
to come back on.
It was like a casual chat in the green room.
But she goes,
you can't do any cancer stuff any home.
She starts listing and I got him all set.
Thanks as much as I would.
I would love to done know,
you know one more let them in or whatever.
We all should have seen this.
What's that line from the comedian documentary?
That Seinfeld dude when already Adam says he goes on the tonight show and they
made him change.
You know there's one person on this bus and that person has a lupus or
something.
And that was his joke cause he was the only person on the bus,
but they made him change it from Lupus to muscular dystrophy or the other way
around.
Like the way they look at words like someone,
they ended debate like a network executive.
I had a debate like which is more offensive lupus or muscular dystrophy.
I'm honestly not even sure which way it was,
which tells you how stupid is.
But what do you think about that?
Just the way,
the days,
the old days,
like you know,
you want it to get on Carson so you could do your five and maybe he invites you
to sit down and if he does right now you're a star that's just,
Oh that's gone.
That's been gone forever.
Now.
I was excited because Jay,
Jay Leno was one of my influences.
People laugh when I say I go go watch Jay Leno.
When he used to appear on the Letterman show in the 80s,
Jay would have month three times a month.
Yeah.
And Jay was the king of stand up at that point.
He would go on there.
Google.
I you've got,
I've,
I still go home and I go over with you sometimes watch Jay is a guest.
How funny he was.
That's what really pushed me.
Jay,
I grew up about 10 minutes from Jay.
He,
I go,
this guy looks like me.
Sounds like me.
He's Italian,
he's Scottish and a and sarcastic.
And uh,
so that was one of my influences.
And,
and um,
but the whole game has changed.
Do you think it matters anymore that like there was a certain,
there was a certain magic to this idea that you could go through that machine.
There was like an actual path to be and success.
Yeah.
That's all gone.
Do you think,
do you miss it at all?
Or the idea that I was just kind of a free for all.
I like it now.
I like that we're all doing our own thing.
Yeah.
And I Kinison I use it as the model.
I Kinison was so offensive and stuff.
Yeah.
But he,
but he became,
it came such a cult had such a cult following and then Hollywood came to him.
Now why don't you get so big,
you know,
you have so many followers and stuff.
Um,
Candice and Sorta did that.
He made Hollywood come to him.
He was outrageous and they finally put them on,
let them and stuff.
I like what's going on like as far as me on my podcast being able to cut loose
and um,
people are looking for you and a guys like you,
and I know this is very few.
I did a gig Friday night in San Diego,
uh,
the comedy palace and I was in San Diego Friday night.
Where are your [inaudible] into that little room?
I haven't done that,
but I,
well,
I was at the Balboa theatre repeaters in,
so that's,
that's,
that's a different thing.
You should have come with a comedy.
I'd pull up.
They're like,
oh,
it's kind of a restaurant.
I go into beautiful comedy rooms set up perfectly.
Probably 150 people maybe.
Yeah,
but San Diego,
a sweet spot for,
yeah,
it was 60% Latino and they loved me.
I,
there's an old,
this is what this is.
When you feel great about being,
as I said,
like a Mexican woman,
the front,
she had to be 65 years old.
She goes to me after the show,
say hi to the twinks.
Those are my two producers in my pocket.
She loved my podcast.
She's like a 65 year old Mexican one.
And when I was doing the religious stuff,
she was hanging on every word and then it was all these biracial couples and a
white guy with a Mexican wave.
What you know,
vice versa.
And then some white military guys and they wanted to hear me.
I'm doing,
I'm going to get real political.
I'm not real when you come to see me now it's a mix,
but my next album is going to be all puck.
So I was going waiting to hear for they were,
they perk up when I go into the political stuff.
Yeah.
Well there's definitely a need for this type of political thing and stand up,
which is what I'm doing.
But that's what I thought I was gonna ask you.
Do you even consider yourself political first say no.
Yeah,
so it's kind of bizarre,
right?
Colin Quinn,
and I've used this at every interview I've ever done,
calling queen set at 20 it goes 20 years ago.
And I said,
I'm not really political.
Comic con not really conserved.
He goes,
Nick.
But he goes,
you have the type of guy you could be,
you could be telling them Mcdonald's joke and people can't tell how you voted,
which is a great quote.
That sums it up.
I go after the macro.
It's more cultural with me,
you know,
I don't go up there and talk about the farm bill.
That was,
you know,
I went in the toilet.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm more macro.
I always pushed the racial stuff because to me that's the,
that's the one,
um,
issue that is the biggest gap between how it's discussed privately as opposed to
publicly.
That's the biggest lie.
And the meat.
I can't watch another home alarm commercial where the five criminals a white,
I said that 20 years ago I've been calling,
I started the whole look in a dumb white father and the commercial on my first
album in 1994 I said it,
I think I was listening to Russia at the time,
you know,
and he sort of may be aware,
but I watch these commercials and it's,
it's just hilarious.
But it's weird how everything's become political,
right?
Like did he use to beat,
I was always doing political stuff.
I was a political science major,
so I was always into early.
Yeah.
But,
but actually I,
I'm so less interested in politics more so now than I've ever been.
I like the cultural thing.
What we're talking about here is cultural in that that's really critical per se.
Um,
but it's weird that everything is politics now.
Are celebrities,
are politics everywhere always talking the Oscars or political sports centers,
political.
It's kind of gross actually.
Yeah.
It was such a media driven society and now the social media has added another
layer,
but it's gross.
It's all about,
so we don't want to have lives outside of,
you know,
you got to do the detox.
I get off on the weekends and I take August,
no phone,
no nothing.
All of August.
August.
No,
no news.
Tried to avoid CNN while you're [inaudible] helicopter.
I can't go to an airport.
I can't go to the gym.
I can't go to the burger joint.
Literally just go into the gym.
I have to walk around like this.
But I,
but I did it because I was like,
I think you've got to escape some of this lunacy.
Oh,
you have or it,
again,
I,
and I don't even realize it,
but yeah,
like I accidentally put on a movie the other night.
I was like rocky free,
whatever,
you know,
nothing but it felt so good.
It actually felt like I was eating cotton candy is as opposed to always put just
flipping out.
But uh,
um,
yeah,
you're right.
I mean,
and actually Joe List is calm again,
comics of that to me a couple of years ago.
He goes,
you watch too much news.
I go,
I have to defend myself from Asheville.
I was like,
yeah,
but uh,
so how do we,
how do we push back against the mob that,
that seems to be the big thing now.
It's like,
I actually think there's some momentum there.
I think we're waking up a certain amount of waking up.
But here's the
problem,
Dave,
what we're watching now is a plan that the left put together 50 years ago,
infiltrating schools and all the institutions taken over,
you know,
Hollywood and it's all comic differ.
That's why they're winning.
I don't think we will be able to,
you know,
I mean,
it'll take 40 years to,
to,
we have to grab back to institutions like,
you know,
like detainment and,
and so what does that mean?
I mean,
well,
I guess we're doing,
we'll be gone right when it will be all we got.
That's the product I am.
Unless again,
unless it comes to violence,
um,
I,
but yeah,
it's gonna take forever.
Oh,
as we have,
we don't as we have is Fox News,
you know,
uh,
Fox are the only ones who put me on there.
They the only ones I can to get my liberal credit left and right.
I can't get a call from the other ones.
I have an interesting history.
Well,
you can't,
you're a gay conservative.
Yeah.
And I don't even call myself conservative.
I'm,
I'm actually a liberal,
but there's no,
I'm a real liberal.
There's no,
there's none of us left anymore.
That's what Louis is.
Louis couldn't be more fair.
You know,
when we used to argue race and Paul,
even when I did his,
his show on Fx,
you know,
uh,
um,
Horace and Pete,
he,
you know,
he wrote my,
and I would,
he would,
let me look at it at first,
you know,
and he looked,
he's an all school there,
but it looks at both sides are thoughtful about it.
But isn't that the irony with,
with what's happened to the comics is that most comics inherently I think are
libertarians.
Most comics want to be able to say whatever they want and live however you want
it know,
and I'm going to live however I want,
but they've been like,
they've been brainwashed.
They've been like,
yeah,
it's even worse.
They'd been just infected by this thing that I guess,
I guess it will in the short term,
give them some success or something.
So it's easy to do it,
you know,
and what's creeping me out.
It seeped into management now.
Like people who run the clubs.
Yeah.
That's what creeps me out.
Is that happening?
I haven't encountered that.
Kurt Metzger get in trouble for doing a rape joke or yeah,
they send them all,
but don't tell him why.
And Bobby Slayton going after,
you know,
Joe out some black woman in the crowd and she got offended and now the helium
doesn't want to use him.
How could you love Bobby slate?
I mean,
um,
and I mean,
where are we done Rickles B right now?
You know what I mean?
And that was,
he didn't hold the right reasons.
Every ethnic joke was for the right reasons because we're all equal in this
country.
You freaks.
He when he was on to let them in a few years ago,
one of his last appearance that's probably going on 10 years ago,
they had a camera and a bar next door,
like in the lobby and the two black older black woman at the bar or whatever,
and Rick calls and I go,
hey,
oh hey.
And they're looking around at the camp,
you know,
what are you drinking them [inaudible] married,
whatever,
ripple and all these,
I'm going home.
Even me,
I'm sitting home gone,
you know,
and they still don't know where the Cameron [inaudible] and then you hit records
goes and they wonder why they can't get any work.
Even the crown of lemons like,
Nah,
you know everybody,
everybody across the board.
Not that you have to,
that's my role to,
I don't feel I need to be balanced because when I sit home and I watch how white
men are portrayed and commercials and on TV and in movies,
I feel no need to balance it out after the show.
People go,
why did you make fun of white people?
I go,
go home and watch TV.
Yeah.
Well,
it does seem like it's coordinated what's going on in this endless of straight
white men and that,
that politicians are doing it constantly that it's about white men.
It's like you are racist.
You people who call everyone racist,
you are racist.
Congrats.
Oh yeah.
You can generalize now about white guys.
Yeah.
I mean,
I've been hearing that phrase forever.
Typical typical frat boy,
you know,
that's code for White.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
You said it's coordinated.
It really is,
isn't it?
I mean,
this is where it's a conspiracy.
Colin Quinn has egos.
It's not a conspiracy.
It's so big that it's not a conspiracy.
That's his theory.
It's not that it's that infiltrated me ever in academia.
They don't even have the kitchen.
And I'm like,
no,
I still think there's 10 guys in a room.
So that's uh,
it depends how far you want to go down.
Like,
yeah,
from a gay naturally,
now two of them are black and I don't know what the other four,
but it does feel like an agenda because they follow a certain,
every commercial has that certain,
you know,
yeah.
That progressive progressive commercials would show US Gillette.
You must have loved that one.
Oh my God,
I couldn't believe it.
That's Gillette as in Robert Craft.
They owns the Patriots.
Right.
Actually.
See,
I'm up.
You know,
I'm,
I'm a die hard patsy.
I go,
I don't even know if I'm gonna Watch the Super Bowl,
but a infuriated.
Yeah,
but how about the progressive commercials?
George shores,
that's one of his companies by the way.
I see have auto insurance.
Yeah.
Those are the worst as far as emasculating white guys,
especially the,
the,
the latest one that I,
the guy,
he's in a,
he's got like a members only jacket on and he's got a black buddy and they're
going out in,
the black guys have bills.
My best friend,
but he's really changed.
He's handing out directions to the club,
get all that he printed out and you know,
can we get some Jalapeno poppers plays and he's get Khakis on and he's playing,
you know,
a guitar on the dance floor.
Just this,
just the,
I mean it doesn't even bother me anymore because I started picking these things
out years ago.
But this one,
it is brutal.
You might have a,
it would be like having a black guy tap dancing and fried chicken and a
commercial that,
you know,
that offensive.
And the movie,
I just watched that movie green book.
Oh,
I didn't see it.
Try to watch that one.
Especially if you're Italian.
You talk about offensive.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I can't believe we don't.
We over God.
Italians have the sentencing,
we have a statue.
They literally have an Italian guy.
He had a wife beat a fold,
a whole pizza
and eat it.
And then the black guy in the movie doesn't even know how to eat fried chicken.
He had never had fried chicken,
was a stuffy,
raised,
you know,
we'll remember later.
He doesn't know how to hold it.
Like a guy who had commercials and infomercials on how to use a camera and
payload.
Is this stuff that happened to you?
I mean,
it's propaganda data.
Remember when,
when Anthony Scaramucci had to step down after two days is Tom's director.
But every joke was about him being Italian and in the month and I didn't see
Italians rioting or screaming and it was just like,
no,
we did all right.
You know?
Yeah.
That's why we can take it.
But I,
I it just this see this movie,
it's why I don't go to the movies and it was so predictable.
I should brew on the ending for everybody.
But uh,
oh,
I didn't know how to,
I've never had fried chicken before.
And he's,
and the Italian guy is just like,
they projected everything like,
uh,
black stereo,
typical behavior on him and his character.
It was just a reverse of roles.
They sat down and literally did cross referencing.
It looked like.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Do you ever get worried that you just,
even though you said it's infiltrating the clubs,
that like management and the rest of Hollywood,
that you're just not going to get other gigs or will be passed up on all that
stuff?
Yeah,
I've given up on Hollywood a long time ago.
Um,
I'll always,
uh,
you know,
stand up,
there's always going to be a place,
even when they're trying to shut down speech,
it's going to make it better for guys like us,
I think in the,
in the long run.
But um,
yeah,
I've,
I've given up on that.
Yeah,
I like it.
I mean,
if somebody wants to throw me in a film or whatever,
I told my agent,
I go up to breakdown,
doesn't say nick,
Nick Depalo type.
I don't want to do it pretty cocky.
Um,
but uh,
thank God to stand up and the Internet podcast,
you know,
you think we're going to be better off in a couple of years or not?
You think?
I
mean that,
that's where we're at,
right?
Like
when you say better off as a nation,
are you and I is uh,
well I mean just generally like just this look,
if we,
let's pretend the civil war doesn't come back in five years.
Where do you think we're at?
Um,
we're on the brink of civil war.
You're,
you're going bullish on this side.
Where else we can go that there's one side that doesn't want to play is one
side.
It has no,
you know,
you can't keep calling people bigots.
People who go out and work and bust their ass blue collar people that make this
country great.
Sounds Corny,
but they do and you're going to keep pointing your finger column racists and
bigots and,
and,
and take more.
They confiscate their money.
Ocasio Cortez and her stupid plan.
Yeah.
Percent.
If you live in New York City and you're over making over 10 million and it's
like,
yeah,
we'd all love to make 10 million doesn't mean the government gets to take it
just because they want to.
And that's confiscation.
But she's moral.
She said it's moral.
That's how they do it.
If you are immoral,
right.
If you are amoral,
they can call you whatever you want.
That's the whole Nazi,
you know,
Trump's in now if he's a Nazi,
you can kill him if he really believed that.
Right.
That's what they do.
That's what gets me the most that sanctimony yeah.
On the left of,
Oh,
they're just doing all the shit that they're claiming everyone else projecting
on us.
It's like,
imagine what it'll be like if these guys have the political power and the tech
power while you're going to do all the time.
Well,
that's the thing.
They're going to do all of the things that they say Trump is doing,
but nobody's in jail over free speech right now.
No.
You know,
it's like once,
my biggest fear.
Yeah.
Um,
that they have,
they have labeled Trump,
you know,
I mean,
just relentless on this guy and they create chaos and people eventually going to
get tired of the chaos.
Even if you like Trump.
That's what I think their plan was.
The left just constant chaos with this guy,
accused them of everything.
And eventually,
even the people in the middle of my God,
we have to,
this is tiring right?
Yet,
even though I love what he's done,
I love how he's exposed the swamp.
I really,
you know,
I didn't like him as an entertainer and stuff.
One of the apprentice,
I never watched any of that garbage.
I loved him for what he's done to expose the,
these liberal fascists in their crazy ideas.
You
most get them to make,
take any position now too,
because if Trump says anything,
they're automatically against it.
So when he's antiwar,
they're pro war.
I mean it's actually an unbelievable,
yeah,
it's like we're scaling back wars and now they're for more war in Syria.
You're first staying in Afghanistan like what the hell is going on here?
I know.
I thought you were the anti war progressing.
Oh,
they soap blinded and again,
and nobody mentioned this.
Everybody ways and why did they hate him so much?
I go because he's an Alpha male,
blonde haired,
blue eyed billionaire.
That's why nobody brings that up.
He embodies the devil for them.
And older white guy,
billionaire,
you know,
Alpha male.
Who Greg says he likes to grab women's posts.
That's,
that's evil to them.
All that is evil.
Nobody ever brings up,
why are,
you know,
they always dance around it on shows on Fox.
And I'm trying to think what you're going to get in the most shit for in the
last hour.
What I'm going to,
what,
what you're going to get in the most shit for it for the last hour.
What do you mean?
Just as you said,
hey,
let's grab 'em by the Pussy.
It's like,
you know,
cause there's always people waiting to watch something for an hour and find the
10 seconds that they can grab them and,
and they'll edit it.
Yeah.
I don't give a fuck.
That's all.
He can't hurt me anymore.
Um,
but uh,
that's not why I love him cause he said that.
I'm just saying,
yeah,
no,
I got you.
But I always had that in the back of my head,
you know?
Oh absolutely.
No,
I don't.
Right before I do an interview,
I go,
this is how it's gonna go.
Um,
what are the,
how are they going to hurt me?
I mean,
going to kick me off my own podcast,
or it's not like I'm on an ABC Sitcom or,
right.
Well,
they could start going for servers and,
you know,
tried to pump everybody off all of these social media sites.
I mean,
that's,
perhaps there's some people working on a solution to that,
if you know what I mean.
I heard that.
I'm praying that it's true.
I'm in the middle of reading his book right now,
that guy or that guy,
and he's brilliant.
And the,
I was,
I get from the book because you're supposed to do the right thing.
Who wants to look that way?
It's very boring.
Yeah.
It's better than the alternatives.
[inaudible] right.
But,
you know,
yeah.
Um,
I,
yeah.
I hope that comes to fruition.
All right.
Well,
all right,
let's,
uh,
let's do a gig together.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Please.
All right.
We're gonna make it happen.
All right,
cool.
Uh,
everybody can follow.
Nick,
can I send them to your Twitter?
Set them to nick.
Dip Dot.
Give Dot.
That's right.
And I can show the Nick Depaulo show.
It's,
it's free on Monday and Wednesdays,
streams on youtube and Facebook live and a few other places.
And then a Tuesday and Thursday.
It's a patriot,
but you can do it all at my website.
And we made it so simple because I'm not a tech guy either,
but nick,
dip.com and that's where you go and come see me live because,
uh,
still my bread and butter,
Nick,
dip.com and don't forget to try the veal.